[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt français au
sommaire aujourd'hui le 10e anniversaire
du printemps arabe
un mouvement de contestation qui s'est
propagée à une vitesse phénoménale et
dont les conséquences ont changé le
visage géopolitique d'une région toute
entière
alors que reste-t-il aujourd'hui du
printemps arabe les séquelles sont
encore nombreuses en tunisie l'économie
peine toujours à se relever après la
révolte de 2011 l'egypte elle est
gouvernée par un dirigeant autoritaire
abdel fattah al-sisi dont la présidence
rappelle fortement les années 2 si
moubarak
de leur côté la libye la syrie ou encore
le yémen sont ravagé par des années de
guerre
un certain nombre d'états arabes a
échappé malgré tout aux conséquences
désastreuses des révoltes populaires et
afin de prévenir leur apparition à
l'avenir ils ont décidé de rectifier le
tir un interne par exemple l'arabie
saoudite et bahreïn ont renforcé la
censure politique alors que la jordanie
et le maroc ont mené une série de
réformes
quelques années après le printemps arabe
une nouvelle vague de contestation sous
coup cette fois le liban l'algérie le
soudan et les rats ces pays connaissent
un changement de pouvoir qui n'aboutit
d'ailleurs pas à un réel progrès
économiques ou sociales
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur cette vague inédite de
contestation qui a secoué le monde arabe
c'est le blick ce qu'on appelle le
printemps arabe commence en décembre
2010 en tunisie
en quelques mois seulement la
contestation gagne l'egypte la libye la
syrie l'arabie saoudite le maroc et
d'autres pays arabes chômage corruption
inégalités sociales voici le fond de la
contestation
les facteurs politiques ont joué aussi
le rôle en pouvoir en place depuis trop
longtemps et une absence presque totale
d'opposition politique
pourtant la lutte pour les libertés et
les changements se paie au prix fort les
pertes économiques causées par les
événements du printemps arabe sont
évalués par la banque mondiale à plus de
900 milliards de dollars
le bilan humain lui aussi est très lourd
1,4 million de personnes sont tuées et
ces événements font 15 millions de
déplacés il ya dix ans le vendée
changement a soufflé dans le monde arabe
et des centaines de milliers de
personnes sont descendues dans la rue
pour exiger des réformes sociales
économiques et politiques pourtant une
décennie plus tard le résultat est
plutôt décevant première à vivre une
révolution la tunisie n'a pas vraiment
amélioré son bilan économique le chômage
reste élevé la corruption ne recule pas
l'autoritarisme contre lequel s'est levé
la population égyptienne n'a pas non
plus disparu or la pire conséquence du
printemps arabe et l'apparition de trois
nouveaux foyers de guerre en libye en
syrie et au yémen
certains états ont cependant réussi à
neutraliser la menace des révoltes
populaires et on fait tout pour qu'elles
ne se reproduisent plus ainsi l'arabie
saoudite et bahreïn ont drastiquement
renforcé la censure politique alors que
la jordanie et le maroc ont démarré une
série de réformes
le liban l'algérie le soudan et l'irak
eux sont secoués par une nouvelle vague
de contestation qui a démarré en 2018
qu'est ce qui est à l'origine de toutes
ces révoltes dans le monde arabe
comment le printemps arabe at il changé
la carte géopolitique de la région où en
sont actuellement les pays affectés par
la révolte populaire
pour répondre à toutes ces questions
nous rejoignons khadr
rim spécialiste du maghreb et de
l'islamisme est directeur de recherche à
l'ipp ce monsieur albert heijn bonjour
bonjour
tout d'abord pourquoi selon vous les
dirigeants renversés comme ben ali ou
moubarak ont cédé à la contestation
populaire pourquoi n'ont ils pas fait le
choix de répression plus forte
ils ont cédé comme vous le dites à la
contestation populaire
parce qu'il est très difficile dans un
pays de gouverner contre le soutien de
son peuple
ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose c'est tout simplement
leurs alliés traditionnels pour ce qui
concerne ben ali la france pour ce qui
concerne le président moubarak les etats
unis ont clairement leur ont demandé de
quitter le pouvoir je me souviens très
bien que madame hillary clinton avait
demandé au président moubarak de
démissionner
donc vous voyez c'est aussi un mouvement
de l'histoire il y a des conjonctions
politiques et des conjonctions
historiques qui font que ces
personnalités ne servait plus les
intérêts des pays et de leur partenaire
comment peut-on aujourd'hui dix ans plus
tard caractériser les événements de
l'époque le printemps arabe
était-il une chose plutôt positive pour
le monde arabe dans son ensemble
au contraire c'est peut-être un désastre
c'est c'est très difficile parce que du
point de vue des sciences politiques
on n'a pas suffisamment de recul ça fait
que dix ans mais ont donc on peut pas
faire un bilan définitif
disons que à partir de 2010 2011
les peuples arabes sont entrés dans un
processus qui est très important qui est
celui de la réappropriation de leur
citoyenneté
c'est à dire de leur destin au sens
social et politique et donc il est
beaucoup trop tôt
et puis on peut faire des bilans très
très mitigé si on parle de la tunisie on
voit que la situation actuelle est quand
même assez mauvaise
et d'ailleurs je relève qu'il n'y a
aucune commémoration de
prévu pour l'anniversaire de la mort de
mohamed bouazizi le 17 décembre 2010 qui
s'est immolé et qui a donné je dirais le
coup de départ à ceux à ce mouvement
général et puis on a vu partout partout
dans le monde arabe des mouvements qui
ont qui se sont souvent soldées par des
violences on se souvient de l'irak
on se souvient de la syrie on se
souvient de la libye et c'est l'algérie
le maroc ont été relativement épargnée
mais les mouvements de contestation sont
présents dans les sociétés arabes et je
crois que c'est ça qui est important de
retenir
maintenant on est très très loin de la
démocratie et de l'état de droit
donc il faut encore attendre un peu pour
dresser un bilan définitif
merci beaucoup monsieur albert heijn
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous retrouverons en
fin d'émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore le 17 décembre 2020 le printemps
arabe
à 10 ans il ya exactement une décennie
un jeune vendeur de fruits et légumes
mohammed bouazizi s'immole au centre
d'une petite ville tunisienne en signe
de protestation contre les autorités
locales qui viennent de lui confisquer
sa marchandise
c'est le début des événements qu'on
appellera plus tard le printemps arabe
le premier dirige ont balayé par la
contestation populaire et le président
tunisien ben ali au pouvoir depuis près
d'un quart de siècle inégalités sociales
chômage et corruption les tunisiens
avaient pas mal de choses à lui
reprocher pourtant son départ n'a pas
vraiment amélioré la situation
économique et sociale dans le pays
depuis le printemps arabe tunisien
le revenu moyen a baissé d'environ 20%
le taux de chômage n'est jamais descendu
en dessous de 15% alors que le niveau de
corruption reste très élevé selon
l'institut de sondage émeraude
consulting la plupart des tunisiens se
montrent pessimistes quant à l'avenir du
puits alors que 84 % de la population
estime que la situation économique se
dégrade
il faut pourtant reconnaître qu'en
tunisie contrairement à de nombreux pays
arabes la transition politique a eu tout
de même
lieu en 2014 la majorité des forces
politiques du pays ont parvenus à
s'entendre sur la nouvelle constitution
un acquis important qui assure tant bien
que mal la stabilité du pays pourtant le
président actuel tunisien kaïs elle
souhaite reconstruire complètement le
système politique du pays en donnant
plus d'importance aux autorités locales
il est désormais temps de revoir le code
électoral et la constitution dans la
libye voisine la constitution est
simplement une affaire à suivre
il s'agit en effet d'une des étapes du
processus de paix visant à faire sortir
le pays de sa deuxième guerre civile
ce conflit oppose deux pouvoirs rivaux
qui revendiquent chacun sa souveraineté
sur tout le territoire libyen
le gouvernement d'union nationale
présidé par fayez al chaar âge contrôle
de vastes territoires au nord-ouest du
pays y compris la capitale tripoli
de son côté l'armée nationale libyenne
du maréchal khalifa haftar appuyée par
le parlement de bengazi exerce son
pouvoir sur la majorité du pays des
années de guerre ont transformé la libye
alors qu'elle était un des pays les plus
prospères d'afrique sous muamar kadhafi
aujourd'hui elle est au bord du gouffre
une petite lueur d'espoir apparaît le 23
octobre dernier lorsque le cessez le feu
est décrété
les deux pouvoirs rivaux démarque
quelque chose qui ressemble un processus
de paix un autre pays la syrie où le
dialogue patine toujours inconnue
artisans des changements radicaux
début 2011 la syrie est un des pays les
plus stables du moyen orient
pourtant le printemps arabe va tout
changer d'abord le conflit civil puis
l'émergence de l'état islamique qui
prend le contrôle de la majeure partie
du pays soutenue par la russie le
gouvernement syrien rétablie malgré tout
son autorité sur plus de 90% du
territoire
or la menace terroriste ne disparaît pas
rien qu en août 2020 les jihadistes ont
mené 35 attaques tuant au total 76
militaires
le conflit syrien est qualifié par le nu
de pire catastrophe provoquée par
l'homme depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale elle a coûté la vie à plus de
380 mille personnes et a provoqué
l'exode
de plus de 11 millions de déplacés et de
réfugiés et ce bilan augmente petit à
petit tant que le règlement politique
reste sur place fin octobre 2019 le
comité constitutionnel représentant les
principales forces politiques du pays
commence ses travaux à genève
son objectif est de rédiger une nouvelle
constitution ou de s'accorder sur les
amendements à apporter à celle qui est
toujours en vigueur
pourtant plus d'un an plus tard le
compromis n'est toujours pas au rendez
vous les avancées politiques manquent
aussi dans le conflit yéménite qui n'est
toujours pas prêt de s'arrêter
après six ans de combats incessants le
pays est déchiré entre les rebelles
houthi et le gouvernement
dapd rabbo mansour hadi ce dernier
bénéficie du soutien de la coalition
saoudienne qui mène des frappes
aériennes contre les positions des
rebelles
même pendant la pandémie les deux
parties se livrent une bataille sans
merci
or depuis avril 2020 une troisième force
entre dans le conflit le conseil de
transition du sud qui revendique sa
souveraineté sur des provinces sud du
pays
famine pauvreté à accès limité aux
services médicaux le yémen fait face à
la pire crise humanitaire au monde selon
l'onu
une situation impensable il y a dix ans
lorsque des milliers de yéménites sont
descendus dans la rue pour exiger le
départ du président de l'époque ali
abdallah saleh la soif de changement
était aussi l'une des principales
raisons de la révolution égyptienne en
pourtant près de dix ans plus tard pas
grand chose à changer inamovibilité du
pouvoir et censure politique tout ce
contre quoi se bat et la contestation
égyptienne est de retour avec la
présidence d'abdel fattah al-sisi
dirigeants autoritaires
il renforce la pression sur l'opposition
durci le contrôle de la presse et en ses
pouvoirs en 2019 al-sisi se réserve la
possibilité de rester à la tête du pays
jusqu'en 2030 via un référendum
alors quels sont les pays qui ont réussi
à contourner la menace du printemps
arabe
comment les révoltes populaires se
sont-elles propagées dans la région
enfin qu'est ce qui a déclenché une
nouvelle vague de contestation dans le
monde arabe
la réponse
après la pause dix ans après le début du
printemps arabe le bilan est plutôt
négative pourtant tout avait commencé
par la révolution tunisienne qui a
produit un effet domino dans le monde
arabe
déclenchée fin 2010 le printemps arabe
mobilise des dizaines de millions de
personnes dans la plupart des pays
arabes
leurs habitants descendent dans la rue
pour exprimer leur colère contre
l'injustice sociale le chômage et les
régimes autoritaires
cette vague révolutionnaire ne se
distingue pas seulement par son ampleur
mais aussi par la manière de protester
les manifestants cours de leurs actions
via les réseaux sociaux
au point de mériter à ce mouvement le
nom de révolution facebook
la tunisie est le berceau de ce
phénomène la révolte populaire dite
révolution de jasmin poussent au départ
le président zine el abidine ben ali
il démissionne et fuient le pays ouvrant
la voie à l'élection d'un nouveau chef
d'état et de l'assemblée constituante
ce succès des manifestants tunisiens
entraîne un effet domino dans la région
le soulèvement commence d'abord en
afrique du nord l'algérie voit des
contestations massive et prolongée
contre le pouvoir d'abdelaziz bouteflika
idem en egypte qui se mobilisent contre
hosni moubarak
les deux mouvements sont marquées par
des violences avec les forces de l'ordre
mais seuls les égyptiens arrivent pas à
renverser leurs dirigeants le pouvoir
algérien lui tente de contenir la colère
publique par des concessions politiques
et économiques limitées
la voie des réformes est privilégiée par
le maroc et la jordanie dans les deux
pays les manifestants parviennent à
faire entendre leur voix en protestant
de manière largement pacifiques les
gouvernements cède partiellement à leur
demande et mettre fin à la contestation
quant à la région du golfe dans la
plupart des pays
le printemps arabe peinent à démarrer
bahreïn est le seul royaume régional à
faire face à des manifestations de masse
elles sont violemment réprimées par les
autorités à l'aide des troupes émirati
et saoudienne dépêchés dans le pays
l'arabie saoudite connaît d'ailleurs
aussi des manifestations limitées comme
le koweït et lohman les trois pays
parvienne à contenir la contestation par
l'argent mais sans éviter dans certains
cas des répressions
or un scénario beaucoup plus violents se
réalise dans nombre de pays
ainsi en libye les protestations marqué
par les répressions se transforme
rapidement en une rébellion armée contre
mouammar kadhafi
l'intervention internationale mène
finalement au renversement du colonel et
à son exécution par les rebelles
profondément divisé le pays reste sans
gouvernance en syrie et au yémen
le printemps arabe où tourne aussi à la
guerre civile des conflit qui s'éternise
le mouvement de printemps arabe
s'essouffle vers l'été 2011
cependant dans les pays les plus touchés
l'euphorie retombe aussitôt refroidi par
la période de trouble désigné sous
l'appellation divers islamiste en libye
et en syrie
l'absence de gouvernement unis laissent
le champ libre aux jihadistes le
cocktail explosif de pétrole trafic
d'armes et intervention internationale
contribue au chaos
idem au yémen l'egypte elle connaît le
règne des frères musulmans qui s'achève
par le coup d'état militaire d'abdel
fattah al-sisi en 2013 en tunisie la
révolution se termine par l'arrivée au
pouvoir du parti islamiste ennahda
dix ans après cette vague
révolutionnaire ses conséquences sont
ressenties partout dans le moyen-orient
y compris dans les pays qui ont su
limiter la contestation en 2011
marraine la fée par la force et depuis
la pression sur l'opposition ne cesse de
s'accentuer sur tous ces dernières
années en 2017 deux principaux groupes
d'opposition sont dissous par la justice
est leurs membres restent privés du
droit de se présenter aux législatives
depuis 2001
8 des centaines d'activistes sont déchus
de nationalité par eni est forcé de fuir
et plusieurs dizaines d'autres sont
emprisonnés exemple éminent l'activiste
des droits humains nabil rajab condamné
en 2016 à cinq ans de prison pour des
tweets critiquant le gouvernement les
peines capitales sont aussi commune et
soulève régulièrement de nouvelles
vagues de contestation ainsi les
manifestations violentes engloutissent
barennes en 2017 et en 2019
après les exécutions d'activistes shit
malgré sa des tendances positives sont
aussi à constater lors des législatives
de 2010 8 6 femmes sont élues dans la
chambre basse du parlement un record en
2019 plus de cent 100 opposants
réintègre la nationalité bahreïnie
cependant tout cela n'empêche pas que
l'opposition reste effectivement privé
de voix politiques au bahreïn et dans
d'autres pays du golfe la situation est
très semblable
ainsi 1 arabie saoudite les appels au
changement pousse les monarques à
adopter certaines réformes sociales des
femmes reçoivent le droit de conduire de
voyager ou de travailler sans permission
des hommes
l'industrie de divertissement et
relancer les cinémas étaient concert de
musique sont autorisés est la séparation
des hommes et des femmes dans les salles
n'est plus si strictes une révolution
sociale selon ryad qui en fait un coup
de com international
or tout cela se fait sur fond de
répression accrue contre les voix
dissidentes des persécutions contre des
opposants sont recensés par les ong
chaque année même les membres de la
famille royale ne sont pas épargnés des
vagues d'arrestations ne cesse de
secouer la cour royale saoudite
un autre exemple effroyable est le
meurtre du journaliste dissident jamal
khashoggi dans le consulat d'arabie
saoudite en turquie en 2018
l'implication présumée du prince
héritier saoudien est pointé du doigt
partout dans le monde allié de ryad les
émirats arabes unis sert aussi lévis à
l'intérieur selon amnesty international
depuis 2011
abou dhabi a emprisonné plus d'une
centaine d'activistes pacifique
pourtant en même temps les émirats et
l'arabie saoudite s'active aussi dans la
région ils soutiennent
des mouvements contre révolutionnaires
et lutte contre les organisations perçu
comme un danger potentiel pour leur
régime cela signifie le plus souvent les
frères musulmans les frères musulmans
sont un vivier de terroristes nous
devons nous débarrasser de l'extrémisme
du coup ryad et abu dhabi soutiennent en
2013 le renversement des frères
musulmans en egypte est la montée du
militaire halle 6 en libye il refuse de
reconnaître le gouvernement de tripoli
où les frères musulmans ont selon eux
trop d'influencé à la place les
monarchies du golfe à puisqu'elle
heifara star homme fort militaire qui
combat les terroristes libyens mais
aussi les loyalistes de tripoli il
s'attaque ensuite au qatar qu'ils
accusent d'être derrière la montée des
frères musulmans dans la région avec le
bahreïn et le koweït les émirats et
l'arabie saoudite impose un blocus
commercial à doha et tente de l'isoler
diplomatiquement à l'international
d'ailleurs le qatar le koweït sont parmi
les moins touchés par le printemps arabe
et ses conséquences les deux pays
traversent habilement l'année 2011 sans
passer à la répression pourtant sans
passer non plus aux réformes de leur
système politique
or d'autres pays choisissent la voie du
compromis
c'est le cas par exemple du maroc face
au soulèvement de 2011 le gouvernement
engage de fortes dépenses sociales pour
créer des emplois et augmenter les
salaires en changement de constitution
étant les pouvoirs du parlement face au
roi plus récemment face aux défis
économiques
rabat entame en 2019 un dialogue direct
avec les marocains
même tendance au dialogue en jordanie
2016 face aux revendications des
opposants un assouplissement du système
électoral a finalement eu lieu
autre exemple toujours en jordanie en
2018 la crise économique et la hausse
des prix de l'énergie provoque de vastes
manifestations les autorités recul
abandonne la hausse des prix et nomme un
nouveau gouvernement
ce processus politique permet aux deux
royaumes d'éviter la chute de leur
monarque
or dernièrement certains pays qui ont
esquivé les révolutions en 2011 sont
rattrapés par un printemps arabe 2.0
c'est d'abord
les soudanais qui se mobilisent en masse
depuis 2018 contre le gouvernement en
février 2019
une étincelle apparaît en algérie puis
en irak et au liban vers le mois
d'octobre tous ces mouvements sont unis
par leurs revendications départ des
dirigeants corrompus fin des injustices
sociales et meilleure gestion économique
pour relever le niveau de vie les
dirigeants algérien et soudanais sont
les premiers à céder abdelaziz
bouteflika et omar al-bachir sont forcés
au départ d avril 2019
après des dizaines d'années au pouvoir
en octobre le libanais saad hariri suit
le pas idem en irak avec la démission
d'adèle abdel mahdi en décembre or leurs
successeurs font bientôt face à la
poursuite de la contestation qui les
accusent toujours de mauvaise gestion
économique après la pause duo qu'ovide
les manifestations reprennent à
l'automne 2020 en irak au soudan et au
liban en algérie en novembre
le référendum constitutionnel ne
recueille que 23 7 % de participation
un camouflet pour le système qui tentent
de mener un dialogue avec les opposants
pour faire le bilan nous revenons vers
kader abderrahim spécialiste du maghreb
et de l'islamisme est directeur de
recherche à l'ipp ce monsieur dream
comment le printemps arabe at il changé
le paysage géopolitique du monde arabe
eh bien disons que les alliances tron
traditionnels se sont globalement
maintenues
il a fallu prenons l'exemple de l'egypte
de la tunisie
il a fallu un peu de temps aux pays
occidentaux comme la france ou les états
unis
pour tenir compte de ces nouvelles
réalités avec des gouvernements ou des
présidents islamiste ce qui était le cas
notamment pour l'egypte et la tunisie
et ensuite business as usual
les affaires ont repris parce que selon
la vieille doctrine de du général de
gaulle les états n'ont pas d'amis ils
n'ont que des partenaires et donc
quelles que soient les dirigeants en
place
les états font des accords des cons
promis avec les gouvernements en
fonction des intérêts c'était le cas
pour la tunisie malgré que ce soit un
gouvernement islamiste c'était le cas en
egypte et puis progressivement ce que
l'on peut appeler la l'état profond a
repris le dessus et donc on a assisté à
des contre révolutions comme c'est le
cas notamment en egypte où il ya eu un
coup d'état en 2014 et l'arrivée du
général du maréchal
si si comme c'est le cas notamment dans
les pays du code très important bahreïn
ou l'arabie saoudite qui ont connu eux
aussi des soulèvements populaires et une
contestation très importante qui a été
réprimée dans le sang
donc aujourd'hui il ya une reprise en
main des affaires courantes je dirais
entre guillemets des vieilles traditions
politique par rapport au mouvement
disons plus progressiste alors il y à
des pays arabes qui ont choisi la
répression mais pour vous les pays qui
n'ont pas connu de changement de pouvoir
majeur ont-ils finalement tiré des
leçons de tous ces événements une très
bonne question c'est vrai que prenons
l'exemple de l'algérie l'algérie n'a pas
connu de mouvement général qu'a vécu le
monde arabe ce qui n'était pas le cas
notamment de son voisin marocain qui a
eu des manifestations avec ce que l'on a
appelé le mouvement du 20 février puis
le roi habilement a proposé une réforme
constitutionnelle qui a permis
d'éteindre tout de suite lincendie mais
l'algérie l'algérie de bouteflika en
2010-2011 avec les moyens de répondre
positivement aux aspirations de la
population et de ce qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'argent en 2010 2011
rappelons qu on était environ à 140 160
milliards de réserves de dollars de
réserves de change dans les caisses de
l'état en fonction des prix du baril du
pétrole qui était à ce moment là très
élevé donc il y avait des marges de
manoeuvre extrêmement importante pour
l'algérie est malgré tout lorsque l'on
constate dix ans après la situation
c'est un chaos total et c'est une
défaite totale pour
régime et par conséquent vous voyez il
n'y a pas de concomitance entre les
aspirations des populations et les
situations réelles c'est surtout et
avant tout une question de gouvernance
et de projets politiques et l'algérie
n'a aujourd'hui ni l'un ni l'autre
récemment plusieurs pays ont connu un
changement de pouvoir par exemple au
soudan en algérie au liban pensez vous
que ce soit des précurseurs d'un nouveau
printemps arabe au ou pas du tout non je
crois pas je pense que dix ans se sont
écoulés
il s'est passé beaucoup de choses en
disant certaines alliances sont en train
d'évoluer
prenons un exemple puisque c'est
l'actualité là aussi qui s'est passé
hier entre israël et hier soir entre
israël et le maroc avec des échanges
diplomatiques et puis la reprise des
contacts politiques de manière
officielle même si il existait de
manière officieuse montre qu'il y a là
une volonté très claire et très nette
affichée du monde occidental de tenir
compte de ces nouvelles réalités et le
président trump l'a très bien compris
puisque lui il va très vite pour faire
en sorte que ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui
ne soient pas des faits par son
successeur dans quelques semaines durent
byden à la maison blanche est donc le
maroc marque des points
incontestablement on peut apprécier ou
ne pas apprécier cette nouvelle alliance
avec israël
allianz officiel encore une fois je le
répète parce qu'il existe des andes et
des relations très anciennes avec israël
au moins depuis 1967 et par conséquent
il faut tenir compte de ces nouvelles
réalités
il faut tenir compte du fait que la
russie aujourd'hui jouent un rôle
important en méditerranée et au maghreb
avec la libye avec l'algérie il y avait
dans les relations traditionnelles que
la turquie est un nouvel acteur
géopolitique au maghreb et en
méditerranée et je vois d'une certaine
manière
alors j'aime pas faire de la politique
fiction mais disons que pour un
chercheur en sciences politiques
on prend un certain nombre de paramètres
et à partir de ces paramètres on essaie
de calquer des impulsions qui nous
paraissent réalistes et aujourd'hui ce
que je
voix c'est la reconstitution des empires
que nous avons connue au 19e siècle avec
près de l'europe à l'ouest l'empiré
ottoman l'empiré russe et l' empire
perse là-bas au moyen-orient dont cette
reconstitution probablement sonne la fin
de la géopolitique tel que nous l'avons
connue depuis le début du 20e siècle et
probablement les prémices d'une nouvelle
et de nouveaux rapports de force en
méditerranée avec de nouveaux acteurs
merci beaucoup kader abderrahim je
rappelle aux et spécialiste du maghreb
et de l'islamisme est directeur de
recherche à l'epsm merci beaucoup pour
votre analyse
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]